well seven years ago who would have
thought a maths teacher could become a
celebrity with pop star like popularity
among of all creatures teenagers if
you'd suggested it as a story plot the
publisher would have laughed you out the
door but that's exactly what happened
when cherrybrook Technical High math
teacher
Eddie work started videoing his classes
and posting them on YouTube
oh we tube as one of his students coined
it Eddie's first book is called Wu's
wonderful world of maths and he's taken
time out of the classroom to tell us
about it any good morning Joe thank you
so much for having me I have enormous
sympathy from whoever is replacing you
in your work with some great teachers at
Trevor technology high school I think
they're doing swimming without me but
it's a real privilege to be here any
people began because you had a student
who was sick tell us the story
the perennial challenge of being a
teacher and working in the you know the
mark and everyone's everyday lives and
all their complexities is you often have
students who rather than you know having
a completely unbroken experience of
school whether it's for overseas travel
or family reasons or in this case
illness there are going to be large
breaks in when they can be you know in
the classroom learning in a coherent way
and a student of mine he was only 15
years old he was actually diagnosed very
suddenly with pancreatic cancer and sort
of the standard procedure that teachers
supposed to adopt is you know said
student is going to be away and we need
to make sure they can try and catch up
and you know stay up to date with the
rest of the class send home whatever
textbook work you're expecting the class
to cover during that time and then
hopefully when they return they'll be
able to pick up where they left off
that's kind of what we're supposed to do
but I knew I mean I was despite the fact
that I'm a mathematics teacher now I
need that when I always at school if
someone had handed me a textbook and
said read this by yourself for five
weeks and just try and make do I knew
that would have been completely
insufficient completely inadequate I
think most of us need someone personally
to walk us through this brain challenge
often abstract subject and so I thought
maybe I could do better than just
painting this kid a textbook and so
that's why I got up my phone and it was
you know one of those really you know
older early generation where they could
just start taking video that didn't look
like a potato and I thought okay I'll
put this up online YouTube just seemed
like the most natural way to do it
because it would be easy for them to
access and from there just that one boy
it kind of spread way beyond what I ever
it could do what difference did it make
to him it's this is actually really
emotional for me to talk about because
the the privilege of teachers is that we
get to take a tiny slice of ownership
over where all of our students get to go
and who they become and this young man
he actually he's in remission at the
moment which is wonderful in itself but
even more than that he actually lasts he
graduated from a computer science degree
at University and for anyone who knows
anything about computer science in
computer science and to be able to say I
I got to hold that door ajar for him I'm
so that he could you know not only get
all that knowledge but I think you know
through my own experience of family
members who've had very serious illness
and cancer I think one of the wonderful
things is to keep on walking through
like a normal person and not have that
disease dominate your identity so you
realized how popular it was getting yeah
look it's kind of funny I mean it was
there were a few moments throughout the
last seven years where I started to
realize oh oh this is this is becoming a
thing rather than just me in my
classroom with my phone I remember the
first time I was just at the shops just
the local shops and I think I was buying
a couple of kilos of chicken wings from
the butcher and the the boy who was
serving me the teenager who was serving
me on the opposite side of the counter
he kind of took my order and then as he
was taking my cash to go and get change
he sort of gave me this funny book and
I'd never experienced this look before I
just be kind of I thought was it
something I said why you became in this
strange way he went away came back with
my change and he said
are you are you a mathematics teacher
and I said yes
are you are you one of my students
forgotten he said oh you're your that
one who puts videos online I said oh my
goodness how did you know about that he
said ah you know a friend of a friend
told me about this and I've been
watching for the last few months and I
thought oh my goodness this is this is a
real resource for people all around the
world all around the country and now
there has been a bit of a learning curve
in you taking all this technology but
it's kind of been nice and gentle and
it's all about just making a better
quality for people you seem to have a
great deal of fun with your classes
seems to feed a lot of laughter that
goes on in the maths and obviously you
have a great personality for teaching I
guess there's a curriculum to get
through not everybody has the same
personality have you ever been asked to
coach teachers I know they you know you
could give 20 teachers listening on
their way to work yeah I'm very
fortunate that within the New South
Wales Department one of the things I do
get to do is run workshops in
professional learning for teachers and
it's it's a real privilege actually just
recently I was at Southern Cross
distance ed and Molly would be high
school and it was a wonderful
opportunity to help encourage and
support the teachers there who are doing
incredible work with a range of really
you know wonderful and deserving
students for me when I think back to you
know University and as an early career
teacher there are so many things that go
into making an effective educator but I
guess the most foundational thing is
what you just said you know rapport and
that connection to students yeah I think
just just like air is the medium for
sound the relationship is the medium for
letting and if you should have a
personal connection to these students
then you're just you're just lecturing
at them and you can't you can't actually
make them any relevant to them so for me
if I wanted to talk to teachers of the
future or teachers now it's that ability
to know a student well and then where
they are uniquely to connect all that
curriculum and knowledge to them at
their point of need that's what makes
the difference
let's get down to some numbers cuz I
know you crunch to them face-to-face
teaching hours have you effectively
multiplied yourself by by doing me a Jew
okay this is actually really tricky to
answer I'm not because I haven't
crunched the numbers because the numbers
are constantly changing so I'm just
going to do this off the top of my head
there's about last night checked about
600,000 people from all around the world
who they've clicked on that button to
say I'm not just I've watched a video
but I would like to continue watching
these videos whenever they come out so
these are subscribers and you know I as
a high school teacher an average high
school teachers about five classes every
year five classes that's 150 students so
if you take those six hundred thousand
people who are kind of watching along
and if you say well how many years of
teaching would it take me at a hundred
and fifty students per year to get up to
six hundred thousand and the answer is
it would take me about four thousand
years to get to that point and I mean I
I hope I hope to have a long career in
teaching but I don't think it'll be
quite that long so I guess that's that's
the joy for me and I mean technology is
wonderful in that it enables so many
different things I'm not about the
technology I'm about what the technology
allows me to do and how it allows me to
connect to students and parents magician
youtuber and now author as well Eddie
did you have fun working out what you
were gonna put in the book wow this is
such a joy I when payment mellon first
approached me and this is today more
than a couple years ago now I remember
thinking to myself do I have a book in
me I don't know I mean I'm flattered
that you would come and ask me whether
I'd like to do this I'm but when I when
I started to think about what I would
put into this I realized I already had
the perfect material I'm a mathematics
teacher I've been teaching her this is
my 13th year of teaching and the
question that every mathematics teacher
gets asked dozens of times every year
and I'm pretty confident that the
majority of people in this room have
asked this question at least once in
their life
several times is sir what where am I
ever gonna use this in my life what
what's the point in me having to learn
all of these formulas and algebra and
trigonometry and all the rest and you
know but the fact that people are
laughing along with me shows this is
something resonates of people I've had
to answer this question hundreds and
thousands of times over the my entire
career and the book every chapter in the
book is one of my answers to that
question here is where mathematics and
patterns and connections are found in
nature in the build world you know the
way the humanity has sought to
understand and you know create an
environment in which we can live in
flourish has been governed and so under
gated my mathematics at every step so
what sort of the coolest phenomena
you've come across that you can explain
using math okay so you know we're in a
beautiful spot at the moment just
looking out the window at the shillelagh
I'm sorry by the way I have to apologize
I think I brought see these rain with me
so everything apparently was fine until
we all arrived this week I'm looking at
I'm just the sky beyond and I'm recently
actually yesterday I saw a red bird I
don't know if anyone else spotted a
rainbow yesterday because you know there
was the rain morning and then there was
this beautiful sunshine afterwards and I
don't know if anyone has recently
thought about the fact that rainbows
rainbows are round I think it's what we
call the rainbows shape like that and I
don't know if anyone has ever
contemplated why it is that a rainbow is
it is in fact a perfect semicircle
that's the shape that you see every time
I remember the first time that my
daughter who's she's 11 years old now
she asked me this years ago and children
have this wonderful way of being
endlessly curious and our key question
after question after question until you
feel like I know nothing about the
universe I don't know the answers to
your questions anymore my daughter asked
me what why our rainbows round daddy and
I thought to myself actually no I don't
know the answer to that question and
there's this perfectly mathematical
object a semicircle that surely that's
not a coincidence so I went it did my
research and what I discovered was and
some of you may already know this
rainbows in fact I'm not semicircles
they only look like semi circles because
they're cut off by the horizon in the
distance
you ever been up on top of a mountain or
in a plane and a rainbow has appeared
you'll see it's not a semicircle at all
it's a full round circle and it's very
few times you will ever get to see
something like that and the reason why
it is this beautiful perfect shape is a
wonderful piece of circle geometry that
has to do with every little individual
raindrop there's millions of them that
form a single rainbow they all act like
teeny little mirrors that reflect back a
different part of the light spectrum and
give us this wonderful beautiful display
that if you were trying to explain it to
someone they wouldn't believe you that
such a thing could exist except there it
is hovering in the sky for us to see so
how'd you learn to be such a good
communicator was it something that
always came naturally to you
I'm smiling when you ask that question
because if you had real if you rewind
the clock and if you go back to if you'd
ask my parents you know his 7 year old
Eddie said 7 year old Edward back then
no one calls me by my 4 maybe except for
my parents or people who think I'm in
trouble
7 year old Edward ever going to grow up
to be a communicator and they would have
laughed your face because I was the I
was right timid very shy in fact that's
part of the reason why I ended up when I
was at school doing four years of drama
in year nine 10 11 and 12 is it for my
HSC I was not particularly good at it I
had friends who went to become stage
actors and went to working in theatre
but from there I learned all these
wonderful skills which you know seems
like they were just for fun and I did
enjoy it to be fair even though wasn't
very good at it but then I realized that
as a teacher what you then have to
become is you have to adopt a persona
I'm a I'm a sort of classic introvert I
don't know you you know when they do
personality test you like are you an
extra man are you an introvert I'm
always about a 90 to 95 percent
introvert on a test and for a teacher
that's a really interesting to be
because you are forming relationships
all day every day and in fact your
ability to teach effectively is founded
in your ability to connect with people
and therefore communicate with
but it is a skill that I've learned and
I've adopted and every day that I get to
be in the classroom and interact with
these young people
it's the privilege of knowing that I'll
be able to without exaggerating change
the trajectory of their lives that for
me is an enormous privilege that makes
me want to put in that effort and you
know it may mean that at the end of the
day when the 3 p.m. bill goes I have to
somewhat curl up in a ball and you know
put my headphones on and curl up with a
book and let my introvert very recover
but it's absolutely worth Arents to
engage kids in school especially if
they're not naturally inclined if they
struggle you know if they just don't
want to be learning for me the love of
learning is something that starts right
from day dawn you know one of the things
that as a high school teacher I
encounter all the time is children are
generally 12 to 13 years old when I
first meet them I do I love working with
primary school children and my kids are
primary school-aged but for the majority
if you know your average you seventh kid
and they have made up their mind about
so much in terms of their you know am i
someone who's good at this subject
am i mathematician am i a reader am i
what kind of a person am I there are so
many unconscious subconscious messages
that we send to our young people that
really do inform the way they then
regard us in the classroom as a
mathematics teacher students walking to
my room and they've decided before
they've even met me whether they are
going to like me or not because I am the
mathematics teacher I stand for and the
subject that they love or a subject that
has been traumatic to them for years of
their lives so I guess what I want to
say the parents is I recognize that you
have this outsized influence in
everything that you say your posture
even little things like I've got many
parents whom I've met and they say to me
well you know I know that my child isn't
particularly gifted in mathematics and
I've said to them look no problem
there's lots of other things that you
can do in your life I totally understand
the impulse to reassure a child
that way but I just I just want to do a
little for experiment you know we're
Australian we we love sport that's just
one of my national cherished pastimes
when a child is not very good at sport
we don't usually tend to respond okay
what don't worry about that you know
that you'll have something else that you
can do in life we would say you're
Australian get out there and kick a ball
like you know just just this is part of
our identity and we recognize that as a
practical pursuit you have to do this
you have to engage with it before you
necessarily have any natural talent if
you're going to get involved and
actually enjoying appreciate this
mathematics is just as practical as
sport as music it's something we have to
engage it and do ourselves so I want to
say to every parent don't give your
child permission to just simply
disengage from that um give them the
gift of saying no you know what I
actually think you can I think you have
the capacity to do this I think you can
read I think you can't play music with
this right I think you can master these
tricky equations I believe in you and I
think it's worth persevering I think
they'll be a wonderful message for every
parent out there to take on well we can
now not only catch you on YouTube we can
pick up a paperback copy of your book
anyway thank you so much for joining us
today